la nuit des musées c'est aussi pour les
enfants une nuit au musée
l'obscurité offre à la visite une
atmosphère particulière et rend plus
fertiles leur imagination
c'est une mystérieure ce groupe
d'enfants et de parents
et parmi les premiers à inaugurer cette
nouvelle édition
ici au musée des arts décoratifs à saint
louis et ne trouvaient le thème des
super intéressant chan d'esclaves et que
vaste et l'occasion nous en tant que
réunionnais de connaître notre histoire
et puis et pme c'est de sentir le
couvre-feu les enfin fini donc mène au
profit de cet appel chez elles à cause
du coc vide l'édition du vin a pas eu
lieu celle de 2021 semble être attendu
le mas doit of actuellement au travers
de mobilier des regards croisés sur le
dix neuvième siècle
vous avez des styles de fauteuils
européen donc le fauteuil voltaire que
vous avez donc ici et le fauteuil
napoléon iii partance de 7 des fauteuils
vous avez une déclinaison qui va se
faire donc dans la zone océan indien à
l'est bourbon le fauteuil de repos qui
réalise en bas jack et celui ci donc qui
reprit donc par len donc on appelle
aussi le fauteuil elle bombay en bois de
en bois noir on est comme dans retour
autour d'eux
passer de ce qui se faisait avant
longtemps donc tout ça est propice 1 le
fait que ce soit la nuit qui sera peu
obscurs comme pendant longtemps avec 40
heures difficile de ne pas se laisser
emporter transportés sur les chemins de
l'histoire entre découvertes étonnement
et enchantement se plonger directement
dans l'époque on peut enfin le dix
neuvième c'est la période des colonies
ou la réunion est une île c'est vraiment
super intéressant parce que le regard
change par exemple dans la nuite plutôt
bien rayonner
oui certainement qu'il doit y avoir des
côtés plus inquiétant est plus attirant
aussi moitié parce qu apparaisse en fait
nous sommes devant une tente rambo mais
du coup comme nous voiler plein voiture
baignoire entrer le dinh van effenterre
c'est quoi et bah nous connaissait comme
un musée mais n'avait jamais rentré de
l'enfant mais elle est bien franchement
une bien trop bien et en plus de cela va
du simple photographie même le meuble
qu'on peut appeler un ancien temps
c'est bien faire découvrir et à revoir
la nuit des musées réussi à séduire de
nouveaux visiteurs
reste ensuite à les fidéliser si nos
collections les intéresse le site
ensuite nous on va proposer toute une
programmation culturelle diversifiée
comme des nocturnes des rendez-vous en
matinée avec des brunchs des ateliers ce
qui nous permet ensuite d'élargir et
notamment de capter ce public qui
peut-être en temps normal ne serais pas
venu au musée sans un événement comme
celui-ci
un événement qui démontre aussi l'envi
le besoin des réunionnais de connaître
leur histoire
aujourd'hui encore trop discrète